good morning everybody it is at seven
o'clock welcome to
wenington in greater london a village
gutted by wildfires sparked by the
hottest ever day on record here people
left with nowhere to go after their
homes caught fire in a tinderbox of dry
grass as temperatures soared past 40
degrees
firefighters called it hell
dozens of fires burned too across the
country we'll bring you the latest on
this story and ask if fires will become
a thing of the norm on today's programme
we'll speak to people
from this devastated community plus the
mayor of london that's sadiq khan and
we'll ask the government what they're
going to do about the very visible
threat of climate change
we'll be speaking to the chief secretary
to the treasury that's simon clark and
also to the met office as well a crucial
stage for the conservative leadership
race too with tensions in the party
rising we'll be joined by the tory mp
tobias elwood for his first interview
since losing the whip for defying his
own government
it is wednesday the 20th of july
britain burns the hottest day on record
sparks wildfires across the country and
leaves residents homeless here in the
village of weddington
we have been told that there is a very
high possibility that our house is
already gone i used to see this kind of
fires
on tv i never thought in my in my
wildest dream that would happen to us
taking shelter in a makeshift refuge
center as the community rallies round as
one firefighter describes the scene as
absolute hell
we actually got the hose pipe cut of
water in cans but after two or three
minutes it was clear it was coming
towards the house
from london
to lincolnshire to yorkshire flames and
a warning that wildfires could become
more common in the uk because of climate
change
wildfires rage across europe too with
tens of thousands forced to evacuate in
greece france and spain
the french president will meet
firefighters here in the south west of
the country while police question a man
on suspicion of starting one of the
blazes
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning
another day another vote with the final
two conservative leadership candidates
to be revealed later on today but who'll
be
the pickup of kemi badenox votes after
she was knocked out yesterday
the cost of living squeeze continues to
tighten as inflation is on the rise
we'll bring you the latest figures
[Music]
hello from weddington people in this
village on the outskirts of east london
waking up with nothing this morning
after their homes were absolutely
devastated by fire caused by the hottest
day on record in the uk
40 degree heat and dry grass a
combustible combination that led to
several buildings catching fire with one
firefighter describing it as hell
wasn't only here dozens of fires burned
across the country as temperatures
sought
one climate scientists told us that
wildfires like these could become more
normal in the uk because of climate
change
dozens of fires broke out across the uk
yesterday in england fire brigades
declared major incidents in
leicestershire parts of yorkshire
lincolnshire hertfordshire suffolk
norfolk
and here in london
at least 14 separate fires sprung up
across the capital from hillingdon in
west london to upminster in the east the
largest fire in the village of
wennington behind me
required 15 fire engines and around 100
firefighters many homes appear to have
been completely destroyed
data seen by sky news suggests that
almost a thousand people in england and
wales are likely to have died in heat
waves so far
850 of them in the extreme temperatures
of the last few days
that figure is much higher than the
number of people who would normally be
expected to die across the whole of the
summer
here's aisha zaheed with the latest
this thick black smoke could be seen
from miles away as the village of
wenington was engulfed in flame
spreading at a dangerous speed the blaze
ripped through buildings and as locals
were evacuated feelings of shock were
shared
i was scared i was thinking it's going
to get to us and i mean it was very
close
and i was just worried
at one point i was numb i didn't know
what to think i was just all over the
place
and my first thing was getting my kids
out i don't even know what to say
because i've never seen i used to see
this kind of fires
on tv i never thought in my in my
wildest dream that would happen to us
the helicopters start coming over
and more police
are coming into our neighborhood and um
and it was it really spreading very fast
as they process what happened residents
gathered at makeshift refuge centers
like this one i'm not sure what the time
was we won't have lunch my son come in
and said uh next door's garden's on fire
so we actually got the hose pipe a
couple of watering cans but after two or
three minutes it was it was clear it was
coming towards the house we don't know
100 for sure but we have been told that
there is a very high possibility that
our house is
already gone i was actually upstairs at
the time and i actually saw from my
window like the flames really close to
the house so
naturally very very panicked only had a
chance to grab my phone
nothing else
following a day which saw temperatures
exceed 40 degrees firefighters fought
numerous places
but what they saw here was unprecedented
we've probably never seen
weather-related incidents particularly
to do with heat on this scale before
but we do have well-rehearsed and
practiced plans in place
the full extent of the damage will take
time to determine but we know that
houses schools and churches in the area
have been affected what's driven the
blaze well it's the dry conditions as
well as the hot temperatures which has
meant the situation has been so volatile
sun said the fire continued to rage home
after home destroyed
this blaze will be a stark reminder of
the dangers extreme heat can bring aisha
zahid sky news
well that was uh yesterday this is this
morning these are the latest images from
the sky copter hovering above uh
wellington this morning and you can see
from those images at what is left of
people's homes
today and they may well be in the
premier inn just behind us looking at
these images yesterday it was their home
today it's just a hollowed out shell
they've lost absolutely everything we
heard from uh timothy stock he's 66.
he and his wife uh maggie live here he
told
one of the national newspapers i didn't
pick up my driver's license i didn't
pick up my birth certificates anything
so i've lost everything photographs
records everything's gone
the only good thing is that we are all
okay you can see the
church still standing in the middle of
weddington but apart from that that row
of houses completely destroyed one or
two properties still there but one
wonders uh whether they will be livable
for the foreseeable future as a result
people have find themselves in the
premier in behind as i said and they are
likely to be there for some time we'll
be speaking to the mayor of london uh
sadiq khan shortly before that though
let's bring in egalia the fire safety
research group leader at the university
of greenwich high thanks for joining us
this morning looking at the images
uh from weddington this morning i mean
there's there's not a lot left is there
for the people who live in that room no
it's uh quite a devastating fire but um
in many respects we were quite lucky
because there's no loss of life no
injury and uh
the number of houses that were lost were
were limited so it's is that down to the
fire service quick thinking of the fire
service uh the fire service would have
had a great deal to do for
containing the fire uh yeah absolutely
okay so what do they do when they get to
a scene like that
well that's a that's that's a difficult
question i mean what what they need to
try and do is um
if buildings are being attacked by the
fire they need to try and suppress the
fire on the buildings but they also need
to protect the neighboring buildings so
that the fire doesn't spread to other
structures
uh and then they also saw actually from
the aerials yesterday didn't we there
was this little natural break which
would have gone down to an alleyway and
so they were putting an awful lot of
water on that just a fire engine coming
through as we
um we've seen quite a lot of fire
engines coming in and out actually as
i'm guessing it's a shift change for now
they've been working really hard they
have been working really hard under very
difficult conditions yeah
yeah so uh they they need to try and
contain the fire but also um tackle the
the wildland fire as well because they
want to try and suppress that at the
same time they're suppressing the the
fire that's spreading to the structures
so they've got a multiple tasks to do
and then they've also got to manage
evacuation uh with with the police uh so
so they've got a lot of things they've
got to do uh on the fire ground and
people don't want we're just hearing
their uh from um tim stock and he was
saying you know i lost everything
it's preservation of life first and
foremost yeah i mean life is the most
important thing and so you need to
ensure that uh
you save as many lives as possible and
and and you prevent injury from people
so that means early evacuation and uh
there seems to be a reluctance to to
instigate an early evacuation in these
sorts of situations uh but it's always
it's always a good idea especially when
you've got high wind as we had yesterday
the fire becomes very unpredictable and
so you really have to move the people
away from the vicinity of the fire yeah
okay and we i know you're going to be
with us throughout the morning so i'll
be with us tonight more at fire engines
arriving here uh all the time as i said
probably um looking at the time we're
heading towards um a shift change sadia
is also uh with us this morning um sadia
good morning you live nearby don't you
um tell us about this area
good morning yeah look when you come
here there's uh there are several
cordons in place where a different one
to the one you're at
and as you drive around you can't really
see much of the fire damage because it's
quite far away this is a you know a very
green area lots of green spaces in
between not that many roads to drive
through to get to the village
but you can tell that there has been a
very devastating fire here because of
these hose pipes these fire water pipes
that the uh fire brigade has put down
you know hundreds and hundreds of meters
of these uh pipes that we can see but
also you can smell the fire still thick
and strong in the air and you know lots
of cold breeze today but you can still
smell that very strongly lots of the
local residents would have had just
minutes if that even to to leave their
property some of them who spoke to sky
news last night talked about how they've
spoken to
the fire service and been told that many
homes have been damaged we understand
that six of them have but people still
don't know whether their properties are
among them
okay sadia thank you simon clark chief
secretary to the treasury uh is with us
hello to you mr clark your reaction good
morning
well these are obviously extremely
distressing images and i think
everyone's hearts will go out to the
families affected by by this awful event
what it goes to show clearly is that
we've got a lot of work to do to help uh
mitigate this sort of extreme climate
events that we're now witnessing and and
this is a reminder today i think of the
importance of tackling climate change
because this is a remarkable
unprecedented event uh and something
which obviously as people have been
saying we are not used to seeing in this
country what we what we've seen over
recent days is not normal and it is it
is a warning sign
you said that delivering net zero is
hugely important and and yet you're
backing this trust who wants to suspend
the green levy which would help in
trying to get to net zero so so how do
you square that circle
that's a one-year mitigation designed to
save families about 150 pounds off their
energy bills at a time when obviously
the cost of living is so
uh is is such an important issue but liz
is completely clear she stands by our
commitment to delivering net zero by uh
2050 and that is obviously something
which this government is working
at pace to deliver we have a 30 billion
pound net zero strategy about changing
our uh energy system in particular but
also of course the shift from petrol and
diesel cars to electric cars all of
these things are are crucial if we're to
make sure that we uh we indeed uh do our
bit as a country to make to make uh good
on ourselves
under the paris mr paris accord yeah
just
sure just looking at those pictures
doesn't matter whether they're
electrical or diesel or petrol they're
all uh burnt to a cinder what are you
going to do to help these people
well obviously people will have uh
insurance but the government will be
looking carefully at what we can do to
to make sure that everyone receives the
support they need and obviously the
first thing is to make sure that they
uh that they have the the support in in
the very immediate term people may have
lost all their belongings as we've heard
their identity documents uh and and i
know our local councils will be stepping
up uh to look after people who've been
affected across uh the country by fires
but clearly central government stands
ready as always to uh
to step in as as needed
yeah so people don't have insurance
you'll help them
well i i'm absolutely certain the
government will look at whatever is
needed to do to make sure that people
are are looked after at a time like this
clearly it's not for me to comment on
specific cases
i'm not asking you to comment on
specific cases but you are giving me a
massive generalization i'm saying if
these people wake up this morning in
this premiere in behind me and they find
out they've literally only got the
clothes they're standing up in and they
don't have any insurance will you help
them
the government will stand by people who
need assistance after an emergency event
as we always do
okay talk to me about um liz
trusts
accusations of
dirty deals vote lending going on um
yesterday it seemed strange that um
rishi soon act only put on three votes
to 118
to get down to the finals three there's
been some vote lending going on
the most important thing is that uh liz
is within touching distance now of those
those final two spots at which point
obviously this reverts to the the
membership of the conservative party the
200 000 party members to choose our next
prime minister i've absolutely uh no
insight into any of this as far as i can
see my
my only goal uh as colleagues is to make
sure that the best candidate goes
forward to the members and in my clear
view that is
that is liz and uh our campaign has been
focused purely and simply on making that
case to our colleagues and and crucially
that's that's succeeding and we want
obviously to continue that that hard
work into today to make sure liz gets
into those final two
to final two slots and gets to make a
case to the membership
yeah uh nothing illegal about vote
lending though is there we certainly saw
that it uh helped boris johnson during
the last leadership campaign do you
think it's happening i i i i've no uh
insight into it to anything of that kind
colleagues ultimately vote for the
person they think is best place to be
uh the next party leader that's the only
possible right thing to do and the only
logical thing to do and uh i all i'm
focused on today is making sure that we
make the case for as many colleagues as
possible that if they want a robust plan
for economic growth so they want strong
defense spending if they want clear
action on the climate then they should
be voting for for liz
and you you don't see it as um
surprising at all that uh rishi soon
only put on three votes
look it's not for me to comment on what
any other campaign might be doing we're
focused as a campaign i'm making sure
that we make the positive case for
liz and she's got a fantastic story to
tell and we've got just a few hours left
now to make sure that we
uh get liz into those final two slots
and as i say make sure that she gets her
chance to make her pitch to the
conservative party membership
uh we're being told that you all want to
clean a campaign um i know that lord
frost tweeted about penny mordent
warning um that she basically wasn't up
to the job um and you retweeted that and
said that it was a serious warning do
you think that's fair play
i think it's very important that people
get to hear about the assessment of the
uh qualities of people who are standing
not just to be the next leader of the
conservative party but our next prime
minister and and lord frost's warning is
not in isolation it's been echoed by a
number of people i think it's perfectly
important that people who have as i say
work closely with candidates get to uh
get to make clear their views this is
this is a robust contest you would
expect it to be frankly because this is
an incredibly important job and uh
people's readiness for that job on day
one is critical that that is of course
one of the reasons why i'm supporting
the foreign secretary someone who's
tested in the highest office and has
held a series of uh secretary of state
ships
okay what happened with tobias elwood
why has he had the whip removed when 12
other mps weren't there either
well there are
there are look i i'm not a member of the
whips office but what i would say is
that there are clear arrangements in
place which all mps understand which
govern the conditions uh for absence
from
votes and of course most especially from
critical votes like emotion of of
confidence in the government which uh
has the potential to trigger uh a
general election uh you can you can
either get permission for extenuating
circumstances people may be ill or have
loved ones who are ill uh or they may
have very very important life events as
i understand it mr elwood was warned
about uh the the seriousness of his
absence he was on a a foreign visit uh
it was within his power to return to the
united kingdom to vote
uh
he was in ukraine and we believe ukraine
is uh number one on the prime minister's
list he's trying to sort out getting
this grain out of odessa so doing
government work he was in the middle of
a bomb threat and the airport that he
would have gone back into the tarmac had
melted so it was shot
he was in moldova as i understand rather
than ukraine he wasn't on government
work he's not a government minister he
is a backbench mp and he was asked to
return to the united kingdom for a
confidence vote which was well committed
chairman of the defense committee okay
this vote was welcome cross about it
okay i'm not getting across i'm i'm
simply correcting the record on this
he's not he's not a government minister
he's a backbench mp that this vote was
known about well into last chairman of
these
that doesn't matter for these purposes
this is a vote in confidence in
imaginative government and that trumps
all other businesses what about the
other 11 what about the other 12 mps
then who weren't there either kay i'm
not privy to the personal circumstances
of all of those mps but there are very
pressing reasons often why colleagues
cannot be there people may be ill as i
say they may have loved ones who are ill
crucially that's for the whips office to
determine they will determine who has
legitimate reasons for absence and who
doesn't this was a vote which was known
about days in advance and mr elwood
chose to go to moldova that was his
decision but ultimately it is also i'm
afraid to say a very a very serious
mistake
okay well we'll be speaking to tobias
elwood who is in odessa
about grain um in the coming hour but
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning thank you thank you
these are the latest uh helicopter shots
for unite
from wellington in greater london
hearing there from the minister that
there will be support from the
government if necessary for those who
have basically lost everything
this morning i can't even begin to
imagine can you just look at the
devastation caused to those properties
last time we had aerial shots from here
we saw these homes blazing we saw the
roof on the one to the left of your
frame there uh collapsed as sarah jane
was talking us through the images
yesterday afternoon and that was the
passageway can you see to the left that
i was talking about there with uh one of
our guests and the fire service uh
heaping water on there yesterday to try
to protect the properties to the left of
that alleyway that passageway and as you
can see they did a very good job and the
other properties there
to the left
we're going to keep looking at these uh
images for you as the police and fire
service go about the work i'm sure that
at some stage today they will be
allowing
those that live or lived in those
properties to return to try to salvage
what they can but let's bring in helen
ann who has inflation figures for us hi
helena good morning
good morning kay yes it's inflation day
again we learned just how much prices
rose in the 12 months to june and
unfortunately inflation up yet again 9.4
in the 12 months to june worth saying
that was actually a reasonably
significantly in excess of what the bank
of england predicted for june the bank
of england predicted to be about 9.1
percent so it succeeded that
put this into context as we often say
the aim for inflation is about 2 so we
really are in excessively high prices
at the moment kay um a few very key
drivers in june the big one was motor
fuels remember last month we did lots of
reports on sky news uh where we spoke
about record fuel prices day after day
those prices beating records well motor
fuels went up by 43
in the 12 months to june so that was a
big one and the other one was food k i'm
at birmingham wholesale market here uh
where there's lots of
fresh fruit and vegetables and meat
poultry being sold out to supermarkets
and restaurants in the area
these guys have seen huge increases in
the prices they're having to pay and
they have to pass that on to their
customers that's reflected in the
figures to food another big driver of
course these are the things that are
very essential aren't they fuel food the
things people just simply cannot avoid
buying and unfortunately things will get
worse before they get better inflation
predicted uh to exceed 11
uh later this year uh things very very
hard indeed for families and it is
crucially one of the big issues that
those leadership contenders will have to
grapple with and probably the thing that
many people in this country care the
most about
okay
thank you if you're just joining us
you're watching the breakfast show here
on sky news this wednesday morning
remember of course prime minister's
questions today the very last one for
boris johnson and of course we will be
covering that for you live here on sky
um we're at accordion these are our
helicopter shots of course we're at a
cordon about a mile or so away from
where these images are
right now we're seeing fire engines
going in a night i'm guessing as i said
a little bit earlier this will be a
change of shift for these firefighters
who've worked so
very hard both yesterday afternoon in
blistering temperatures 40.3 degrees the
hottest ever day in the united kingdom
which caused we don't know the actual
cause of this fire at the moment but
certainly as a result of whatever caused
it there was the brush fire here in the
scrub land around and that moved to this
row of houses some 300 people live in
wennington just on the outskirts of
london speaking to the mayor of london
sadiq khan in just a short time
and
yeah you can just see the church there
as we're just moving out of shots said
mary's and saint peter's that did
survive but sadly
at least six other properties did not
we also heard about the fire station
didn't it was damaged by fire again
yesterday afternoon the people that
lived there the police came to their
door they had no time they said grab
something to wear and get out of the
house and we need to move
now and we've been hearing from some of
those who did move and said they've
literally lost absolutely everything
apart from what they are standing up in
waking up in a hotel just behind me here
this morning perhaps watching these
chopper shots as you are
as you get ready for
work or school spare thought for these
poor people and the state of the
property that they called home until
yesterday joe wheeler standing by for us
joe um
the worst of the hot weather has
subsided for now
it pretty much has i mean it was
obviously extraordinary with so many
records broken right across the country
but a higher forty point three never
been seen in this country uh before and
of course it's not just the fact that it
was so very warm yesterday i don't think
you can see behind me but the lawn is
tinder dry we've had virtually no rain
and everything is uh parched and of
course that is classic uh classic
situation for fires to start and those
terrifying wildfires which hitherto
we've only really seen abroad and and
not here it's been a very stark shock to
us all i think and then today such a
dramatic change uh we've seen atlantic
air coming in from the west some of the
warmer is going to hang on over eastern
part so again parts of lincoln you could
still see 30 degrees today i know that's
10 degrees down on yesterday but for
many parts of the country temperatures
will be 10 to 15 degrees lower and on
top of that we've got some showers early
on this morning those starting off in
the southwest uh likely in the east as
well the far east parts of east anglia
and the far southeast but then through
the course of the day we'll see more
showers bubbling up in the south those
likely to transfer their way eastwards
and there is once again a warning out
for these thunderstorms because we could
see some torrential downpours gusty
winds to go with and also the risk of
some flooding on the roads how weird
does that sound when we were looking at
fires yesterday and today we could be
looking at flooded roads and obviously
some difficult driving conditions and as
i say temperatures typically mid 20s for
many but perhaps reaching 30 degrees
celsius once again in the warmest spots
okay thanks very much indeed thanks a
lot
so that's the situation here in the uk
we are in wennington in greater london
on the breakfast show for you this
morning they've had big problems around
europe as well let's have a look at
what's going on there should we extreme
weather
uh
right around europe have i got some more
to cue yes i have temperatures are also
causing wildfires in greece fires have
been burning in the mountainous region
of pentelli near athens more than 400
firefighters along with planes and
helicopters have been deployed to try to
control the flames
in spain hundreds of heat-related deaths
have been reported over the last few
days fires are still burning in galatia
and castilla illion where thousands of
people have been evacuated from their
homes
the french president emmanuel macron is
set to visit the girond region in the
country's south west today more than 37
000 people have been forced to evacuate
in the area and many don't know if their
houses will still be standing when they
return
let's go to france should we at siobhan
standing by for us this morning hello to
siobhan tell us more
hi kay well i'm at the hq this is a huge
temporary operation that they've set up
over the last week you can see behind me
there this is how big
the scale of fighting this fires is you
can see those trucks there this is a
24-hour mechanic area so that when those
fire engines come back in on a rotation
any problems get mended overnight they
then go back out we've just seen loads
and loads of fire engines going out past
us possibly a shift change this morning
but the good news from here is that the
two massive fires that they've been
fighting for the last few days haven't
got any bigger they don't seem to have
progressed overnight so that is good
because really over the weekend and on
monday evening they were really really
testing these fire crews to the limit
now this afternoon we're expecting
emmanuel macron to come to the area to
meet firefighters to have a look at the
damage we managed to look at the damage
of
some of the campsites that were burnt
down yesterday it was absolute
devastation totally wiped out you can
see the little areas where
the chalets used to be toilet blocks
just burn all twisted metal the heat of
the fire this isn't over here though
okay it is smoky today it started to
rain it's much cooler but they are
continuing to battle those two fires
okay siobhan thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot well our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter has
also been out and about for us uh in
spain actually north west spain and she
sent us this update
in spain a searing heatwave has fed a
series of devastating wildfires some 30
or so are still burning firefighters
struggling to get them under control and
it's a particular problem here in the
northwest of the country where we are in
the town of zamora and in the mountains
around this town
tens of thousands of acres have been
burned two people have been killed
thousands of people have been evacuated
and the spanish prime minister has
warned that there is worse to come for
this region as temperatures climb again
many communities remain evacuated as
they watch those temperatures increase
these very hot
very dry conditions all being made worse
by climate change feeding these deadly
fire events and causing misery for this
country and across europe
well here in greater london for us this
morning professor ed gelia the fire
safety research group leader
at the
university of greenwich thank you very
much indeed um
we've been talking earlier this morning
about um what the fire service did and
what the police service did when they
first got here for people who were just
tuning our way they did it by the book
really didn't they
yeah they i i that they followed their
procedures and and they tackle the fire
in in an appropriate way yeah okay
is there a buck coming well i i think
i think we have to understand the
significance of the events that we
witnessed yesterday i think we've seen
the nation's capital
first
property loss due to global climate
change and wildfires that's very
significant and it speaks to the need to
improve our resilience in london
this text this fire and all the other
fires around london really taxed
the london fire brigade
what would have happened
had we had a grenfell event at the same
time as these wildfires
would the
services been able to cope with that i
don't think they would have
and so
due to this global
climate change and due to the impact
that it's going to have on
the propensity of having more of these
types of wildfires we're probably going
to need to see
a
increase in the number of firefighters
we have increasingly in the equipment
they've got the type of equipment
they've got and the type of training
they have to be able to to cope with
these types of incidents so what do they
need to do what exactly is it that we
need to do is it more of more fire
engines or do we need to look at
i think there's a whole range of things
as soon as you bring wildfire into the
mix uh it's it you've really changed the
uh uh
the
the the nature of of what it is your
firefighters have to deal with and so
you need to change the training the
equipment they need more equipment
they're probably going to need more
firefighters to cope with all of this
and
potentially we're going to need
different types of equipment for example
if we're going to see wildfires
of this scale and greater and remember
in 2011
the nation had a wake-up call the
swindly fire 2011 was a devastating fire
uh but we were lucky because the weather
worked in our favor that at that point
in time but 300 firefighters were
engaged in that one fire
it came very close to
uh habited areas it came very close to
broadmoor prison hospital it came close
to sandhurst it came close to national
infrastructure power uh generation and
transmission uh you know and that was
2011. that was a big wake-up call for
for the uk but we
have to deal with wildfires in this
country and professor we will pick up on
what we've learned since then um later
on in the show for now thank you very
much youtube for joining us thanks a lot
because i want to go to odessa now in
ukraine and bring in tobias elwood mp
and hello to you mr elwood you no longer
have the tory whip i put that to a
government minister this morning he says
it's your own fault you should have
known better
yeah well i mean firstly it seems a lot
quieter here in odessa perhaps than back
in london at the moment but yes i i
didn't factor
in enough time given the travel chaos
that then ensued after meeting the
president of moldova not something that
you do every day i deeply regret losing
losing the whip i do hope it's only
temporary
you were told to come back it's what the
minister said but you ignored government
advice and it was very serious
no i didn't ignore it at all i kept the
whips office informed
the entire time there are a few options
to get back but there were problems with
travel
in the uk runway's melting i understand
and there were also
uh security issues in moldova too and
combination of that meant that the the
few options i had to get back in time
for that vote uh then disappeared and
yes i'm uh very sorry i didn't make it
back uh
so
there's not more i can say
a very serious mistake is what simon
clark said what do you expect to happen
next
well i think it's only temporary that
we know that there's new leadership
coming in
uh i'm saddened that it was filled out
in a big debate i think the nation has
probably had enough of the blue on blue
you know wider picture step back from
this it does feel in the last couple
weeks that we've lost our way a little
bit
uh it's been a sad chapter in the
history of our great party that the
nation wants to be
impressed and inspired and they're not
demoralized but what they're witnessing
right now and uh we need to perhaps
exhibit greater decorum dial the
temperature down a bit showcase the
ideas the vision focus on those things
are important that the nation wants to
see that's what will earn us the right
to stay in government otherwise we're
just going to be letting ourselves down
and indeed committing ourselves to
probably a long time in opposition
are you able to vote in the leadership
debate uh leadership contest later on
no sadly that is uh one privilege that
uh unfortunately i've now lost i was
very much supporting uh penny morden one
of the reasons why is because of where i
am here
today uh there is unfortunately
propaganda here pushed out by the
russians that
any new leader that comes in will not
have the same commitment to ukraine and
to face such as odessa i'm pleased that
not just any but i think all leaders
will continue our support for all this
country which is one of the reasons why
i'm here
uh let me just i want to come on to that
if i may but just to finish on the point
of the fact that you can't vote for
penny morden george freeman who you know
is helping run penny morden's campaign
said yesterday on the radio last night
boris johnson wouldn't have removed the
whip from tobias elwood had he been
supporting liz trust do you think
there's any truth in that
i again i mean i'll be then fueling the
blue on blue which i'm actually trying
uh to avoid uh so i'm
i hear george he's a great friend
of mine again another supporter of penny
morton itself
let's say high let's focus on what uh on
how we can move forward and make sure
that we conclude this leadership
campaign uh to the high professional
standard that i think the british people
want to see
are you quoting michelle obama there
were you when they go low we go high
well i think that's a great inspiration
i think we perhaps lose sight of that in
politics there is the frenzy of the
event itself that's very easily i have
to fire from the hip to express your
views and your anger but it's important
to remember that as i say the british
people are watching all this day by day
hour by hour and uh this is an
opportunity in this leadership to
actually uh exude some of the ideas some
of the uh
the the the discipline that was missing
in before but most particularly the
vision of where britain britain needs to
go you've just been discussing some of
the challenges domestically
internationally as well we need
leadership in britain and we need
leadership in europe as well that's
what's missing there's a gap in the
market for that and i want britain to
fill that gap
okay as we continue to
look at images of wennington and the
destruction that was caused by those
wildfires yesterday tell me why you're
in odessa
and on uh who's authority
well firstly i was in moldova meeting
the president sandu there she's very
nervous indeed
mikhail is only 60 miles away that's the
front line and if that falls odessa here
becomes the front line russia wants to
take this city
the russian empire included this as
their big war water port and uh they
want it back and uh that then means uh
moldova is then on the front line
they're calling out for help and i hope
britain will respond uh to that more
importantly though behind me is the
black sea uh we have three big ports
here and they provide the grain for the
rest of the world we've learned to
understand that ukraine is the break
basket of europe and beyond but as you
see none of the ships are moving so i'm
here to see whether there's a plan that
we can remove odessa from the conflict
turn it into a un humanitarian safe
haven which then means that the ships
can be filled with the grain and then
move out here down through the
prosperous strait uh potentially
protected by a coalition of the willing
but under a u.n mandate if we don't do
this then not only will ukraine's
economy uh suffer but also the cost of
living crisis in britain will be
affected because the price of grain will
remain high or critically there's
countries such as egypt lebanon somalia
yemen where you'll see mass starvation
famine and so forth which will cause
even more problems for the international
community there is a solution here that
we could pursue and i do hope britain
will support this
okay it's uh good to talk to you uh
thank you very much indeed for joining
us mr elwood uh hopefully you will be
back safe and sound in the uk before too
long thank you
thank you
tomorrow standing by for us this morning
hello to you tomorrow as
these are returning to live shots and
our live images
from
actually these are the latest images
sorry about the latest images from
wellington this morning and the
destruction that has been caused by
those wildfires yesterday officially
being told six properties were destroyed
but you can see the aftermath of
those fires that raged out of control
for quite a lot of yesterday as
temperatures reached
40.3 degrees the hottest ever recorded
here in the uk as promised tomorrow is
with us hello to you um tomorrow hearing
there about um dirty tricks and also
about the the whip being removed tell us
more
that's right well today is the final
round of voting if you thought it was
never going to end in the tory
leadership contest and we will see the
final two candidates emerge who will
then have the whole of the summer to set
out their stall to conservative party
members before the new prime minister is
chosen in september but last round of
mps voting and essentially it is a
last-ditch scramble for votes between
liz truss and penny mordant who both
want to be in second place almost
certainly alongside rishi sunak who is
set to gain a place in the final runoff
and so with only six votes separating
them yesterday every vote counts and
there are accusations that the whip was
removed from tobias ellwood who was a
key supporter of penny bordened and
someone not very much liked by downing
street because he has been very critical
of boris johnson the suggestion is that
it was removed from him for that reason
that is denied by
the government and tobias elwood that we
did suggest that he had been a victim of
what he called blue on blue hostilities
conservatives turning on each other and
it was time to come back together
afterwards so there will certainly be
more controversy about that if it is
very very close when we spoke to simon
clark treasury minister and supporter of
liz trust he said that she was getting
very near to being in the final two this
is what he said
the most important thing is that uh liz
is within touching distance now of those
those final two spots at which point
obviously this reverts to the the
membership of the conservative party the
200 000 party members to choose our next
prime minister i've i've absolutely uh
no insight into
any of this as far as i can see my my
only goal uh as colleagues is to make
sure that the best candidate goes
forward to the members and in my clear
view that is that is liz
he says he doesn't know anything about
dirty tricks although there are a lot of
confusion about the some of the numbers
that emerged in that ballot yesterday
particularly that tom tugan hats votes
many of whom appears in the liz truss
column which is not what colleagues
expected although one official working
for one of the other camps said it's
hard to know what is malice and what is
just churn of votes at this stage but
we'll get the result at four o'clock
okay thanks so much tamara thank you
lots coming up today actually as
tomorrow was saying uh it's the final
prime minister's question time for boris
johnson certainly appearing in the
commons for what will be his uh last pm
queues of course you can watch it live
can't you hear on sky yes you can it's
at midday the final prime minister's
question time for boris johnson midday
today and a reminder mps will voters
tomorrow is saying for the last time
today to decide which two leadership
hopefuls should go through to the runoff
vote among conservative party members
grassroot members as we call them about
150 000 or thereabouts worth bearing in
mind that that is 0.3 per cent of the
electorate which means that 99.7
of the electorate will have no say in
who is the next prime minister sadiq
khan the mayor of london is with us now
um hello to you mr mayor lots to talk
about what if we could just pick up on
that do you have a view on who you'd
like to see as the next prime minister
yeah i do it should be kirsten i should
i think whoever wins the tory leadership
contest
should call a general election so the
british public can have a choice to have
a fresh start all these candidates
are continuity boris johnson they
supported defended and have enabled him
to be prime minister for more than three
years and i think the british public
should have a say rather than just those
who are members of the tory party
uh well you know that's not going to
happen do you have a view of which of
the of those three
well well no i i think uh rishi sunak is
the architect of what we've seen in the
last two three years in relation to our
economy
uh you know we know liz trust is a big
ally of boris johnson
i know less about penny penny morden but
you know the reality is all three of
them have been big supporters defenders
and enablers of boris johnson what's
important though is until
the new lead is elected we should have a
prime minister doing his job and i think
what boris johnson should do is step
aside uh he can have further parties and
you know become tom cruise and allow
dominic raab to be the caretaker prime
minister because we need a full-time
prime minister looking after the
well-being of our country rather than
somebody who's checked out
okay let's talk about the concerns of
the people who used to live in these
houses that we're looking at at the
moment or on a split screen so we can
see while we're still talking to you mr
khan
it's within your remit you're
responsible for the welfare of these
poor people what happens now
so yesterday was the busiest day for the
fire service in london since the second
world war on a normal day the fire
service receives roughly speaking 350
calls on a busy day 500 calls yesterday
they received more than 2 600 calls
more than a dozen simultaneous fires
requiring 30 engines like the one you're
at a couple requiring 15 some requiring
12 some requiring 10 and that's why the
fire service declared a major incident
i'm afraid the bad news is as we can see
from the images 41 properties destroyed
in london 16 fighters were were injured
some extent too taken hospital because
of heat stress it is really important
though for us to recognize uh that one
of the consequences of climate change
and these sorts of temperatures which
lead to the sort of fires you're seeing
behind you the challenge in london is
we've got a lot of grass uh you know a
lot of green spaces but a lot of it
impinges on properties and we've had
rain for a long period when the grass is
incredibly dry fires can start very
quickly and spread even faster because
of wind and that leads to properties
being uh destroyed the good news is uh
the fire service today
will be providing an excellent service
the first fire engine today will reach
you within six minutes six minutes the
second [ __ ] engine within eight
yesterday it was taking 20 minutes
because of the pressure the fire service
was under
you said 41 properties destroyed sorry
can you just um tell me a little bit
more about that
yes a number of properties across london
destroyed some homes as we're seeing
some warehouses and other properties as
well and a major factor was in some of
these properties being destroyed was
their proximity to grass you know many
properties in london are next to grass
and it's similar to what you see in
california and in the south of france uh
in relation to fires next to densely
populated areas uh so in this country uh
the main fires of this scale we see is
the national parks or the moors which
don't impinge a property unfortunately
in london many of our properties are
like it's a good thing
for the vast majority of time many of
our properties are next to green spaces
but one of the downsides is when you
have this exceptional weather this uh
you know red alert level four according
to the met office uh you know you have
situations where fires can start easily
and spread even faster
this area is not within the ules zone
euler's are very important to you of
course isn't it in trying to
tackle climate change um
is that something that you're going to
have to look at and spread that area
right even further
well there's one thing that really makes
me angry in relation to what we've seen
in the last few days is it takes
what we've seen in the last few days
this extreme weather this heat wave
level four regular uh at the same time
there's a leadership contest to choose
the next prime minister and no one's
talking about the elephant in the room
which is climate change causing the sort
of heat waves where temperatures are
exceeding 40 degrees we've got a
situation where we have heat waves every
two or three years rather than every 10
or 15 years and the temperatures aren't
mid-20s they're approaching 40 degrees
if not higher leading to the fires we
saw uh yesterday and many excess
deaths and what we should be doing is
dealing with the consequences of climate
change and air quality cleaning up the
air
less premature deaths less children with
stunted lungs less carbon emissions but
also dealing with the causes as well and
what we're doing in london is dealing
with the causes of climate change and
air quality by
having policies that reduce carbon
emissions reduce nitrogen dioxide reduce
particulate matter like cultural
emission zone plant to record numbers of
trees having water fountains across our
city cooling our homes air conditioned
new trains but we need support from the
government as well because we can't do
it alone and the only people that can
really support us to tackle climate
change in terms of the causes but also
the consequences are the government
rather than us kicking the can down the
road we should be sprinting to get to
zero carbon
so you're saying the government's
failing on on climate change on their
climate policies so what are you
suggesting
a number of a number of things we can do
one of the biggest issues we face are
energy bills that's because we're
relying upon you know gas and oil from
you know russia or qatar or saudi arabia
why don't we use this crisis as an
opportunity to invest in wind and solar
so we're not relying we have energy
security and it brings the bills down
one of the big challenges we face
post-brexit is what's the future of our
economy i think it should be
high-skilled well-paid jobs why don't we
be invested in people insulating
people's homes installing cooling
systems putting double glazing in that
will lead to energy efficiency less
carbon emissions but lower bills because
homes are more efficient district
heating pumps so we should be you know
be the people that are solving these
problems uh using the opportunity of a
crisis to create prosperity and wealth
rather than kicking the can down the
road asking for a green pass rather than
doing these big challenges you know a
lot of the problems we have today are
direct consequence of climate change
excess death because of the heat wave
the sort of fires we saw yesterday
energy bills are escalating uh you know
people being in
jobs that aren't well paid lower skilled
jobs a lot of these problems can be
solved by tackling climate change
expediently
rather than you know rather than kicking
the can down the road
and what advice are you giving to the
people of greater london over
the next few days i mean it is getting
cooler now i i heard talk of barbecues
being banned certainly uh in parks i
know that when they have um hot days or
used to when they had very hot days in
australia barbecues were just banned no
one could have one even in their back
garden
yeah look these are exceptional times
and because of uh the ease with which
grass is catching fire and the the speed
with which it spreads
we are advising people not to have
barbecues
not have barbecues in your balcony
at parks nor in your private garden for
today these are exceptional times which
call for exceptional measures none of us
wants to be a party pooper but how would
you feel if you had a bbq in your back
garden and uh some of the grass which is
like hay caught fire and it's spread uh
damaged your property risked your
well-being and spread to your neighbors
our firefighters are working incredibly
hard they're they're they're they were
the heroes yesterday they need some
respite as well a very simple thing we
can do is just another day uh without a
barbecue and please also if you're near
water don't be tempted to jump in
whether it's the thames whether it's a
canal or whether it's you know other
forms of water over the last few days
across the country we've seen nine
people losing their lives in london
tragically a 14 year old child jumped
into the river near hampton his body was
recovered yesterday so let's try and be
sensible whilst we're going through this
heat wave to support public services but
to support each other as well
um we must leave it there mr mayor thank
you for sparing your time for us this
morning much appreciated stay safe
thank you you too assistant director of
kent fire and rescue service matt
deadman is with us now hello to you
uh thank you for joining us this morning
um looking at these images i mean the
firefighters did absolutely everything
humanly possible today and yesterday to
try to contain this fire what will be
happening today
yeah so as he's had really really
challenging time over the last 24-hour
period as was expected with the extreme
heat that we're seeing
both within kent here and as you can see
from the pictures elsewhere up and down
the country um firefighters is working
incredibly hard in extremely punishing
conditions uh to limit the spread of
these wildfires that we're seeing
we've had a significant presence a
number of large scale incidents such as
those we've seen on the heath in
particular in dartford in the southeast
area of london
and around the surrounding areas today
and we scaled down operations overnight
um due to the darkness today we'll be
standing resources back up in order to
finally resolve those incidents turn
over damp down those scenes and take
stock of where we are we've got a plan
going into place as you would imagine
for the remainder of the week in terms
of making sure that we have enough
resources to meet any of the challenges
that the weather may continue to present
us as we go forward
okay uh so just to clarify was it kent
or london firefighters that was the lead
on this fire
uh the wellington incident uh that was a
london fire brigade uh incident um kent
has uh obviously joins um close to that
area but on the
stage and we were dealing with similar
heathrow and type fires uh in the
dartford area
so what can you tell us as an update
about um
was there any injuries to be reported
and how many properties were damaged
so fortunately here within ken uh the
property damage was relatively limited
uh we had a serious house fire in barrow
green um but in the dartmouth heath area
we managed to uh prevent the spread of
fire from the heathen to surrounding
properties um through putting in place a
large number of resources at one time we
had 150 firefighters and 35 engines on
scene working hard to make sure that the
public uh remains safe
and obviously
just in terms of what the public can do
to help us as we move forward over the
next 24-48 hours you've just heard today
on there outlining some of the safety
messages
around ensuring that you're not having
fires in the open um making sure that
when it comes to things like water
safety you're treating that with
absolute respect not jumping into rivers
and so on which of course would help to
ensure that our response can remain
resilient through this period and that
we're only then required for the most
serious uh of course
okay well thank you so much sir for
taking the time to join us hopefully it
will be acquired today for you and your
men and women today thank you thanks a
lot um these are the latest images from
wenington uh in greater london uh the
morning after the day before when uh as
you can see a brush fire now out
hopefully
swept across the landscape here
absolutely devastating this small
community only 300 people live here
basically that's it it's just one road
what you can see is this village in
greater london this morning six of those
properties have been absolutely
destroyed everything that was inside
those properties now gone those that
live there
are in
a hotel behind me what happens next
we'll have to wait and see